我们女人啊，
老是泄露那种逻辑，
就是说哎呀，
她没瞧上我，
我就没自尊了，
我跟你说你们都去学那个谁袁咏仪，
袁咏仪当时追张智霖嘛，
那人家就说，
那你要是追人家，
人家要是不同意的话，
那你怎么办？
下一个喽，
你们真的都去学一下袁有仪这种态度，
男人这个东西就是这个不行，
下一个喽，
比如说这个不喜欢，
我就表示我不好，
就表示我不值得，
就表示我没有魅力，
想上下一个，
我今年35岁，
我都是农村的，
我有一个弟体一的慢慢弟体是有精神类的疾病，
基本上没有自己的生活的那种能力吧，
我目前主要是自己在养一个临时的，
也不是有体制内的那个工作，
年薪大概有40个左右吧，
我们大概想自询的话，
就是刚来这边的时候，
就是我的老板嘛，
跟我表达了一些好意，
就大概几个月之后在一起，
他提了分手，
老板应要了，
这个单身大，
比我大三四岁，
因为他跟我在一起，
他的年纪大概有90~100个左右吧，
他就是不是很想和我公开关系，
就导致我跟的时间就有一点抑郁，
可能说话也比较冲满，
过了一段时间，
然后去成手了，
他分手之后立马就接触了新的人，
现在应该是有新的对手，
女后三这游戏也没有对象，
我就感觉我工作环境。
我不知道我还要不要在这里发展，
我有点想辞职，
但是他这边缺了人，
之前我提过他就会也有挽留，
但是目前的话，
因为我35岁，
要是要进去之内了，
不可能要立马都辞职去找体的工作，
但是第一方面就是来这边一年都快两年了，
我的产品出也没有出啊，
体制内这个事儿是你想尽，
你就有这个能力，
有这个把握马上就能进的吗？
在一个高校吧，
非那是没有问题，
那你现在这份工作年薪40万，
这个工作本身的内容让你满意吗？
还是说因为和领导谈过恋爱，
因为他跟你分手了之后又找了别的对象，
所以你在这也觉得尴尬，
所以想走，
工作本身我还是挺喜欢的，
但是我感觉这个领导他这有点欺骗性质的，
让他比较痛苦，
如果你只是觉得跟他的因为有涉及到男女情感这件关系了，
觉得尴尬和痛苦的话，
那我们要转变一个思路，
不要跟钱过不去，
就是大大方方的承认这句话说出来，
姐妹啊，
你要辩证的理解我这个话，
我不是说故意伤害你说这个话，
但是我想说这个话让你心里明白这个底层和逻辑，
就是他从一开始就没看上我，
他就想我而已，
你知道吧，
但凡看上你了，
他就公开呀。
男的谈恋爱，
如果说对一个女的特别满意，
特别看得上的话，
他特想公开，
他不光想炫耀给同学看，
老师。
看朋友看兄弟们，
看他想炫耀给全世界看他之所以不公开，
就是他没有看上我，
没关系啊，
他没看上我不是我的问题呀，
他没看上我是他的问题呀，
只是他没看上我而已呀，
他没看上我，
但是他看上我的工作能力了呀，
我在这儿，
我挣这40万，
我挣得心安理得了呀，
我工作能力是配得起这40万了呀，
工作是一码事儿啊，
男女关系是另一码事儿啊，
是他在工作上面好像是还平看着婚啊，
对呀，
那就证明我值这40万呢，
在男女这件事情上，
他没看上我，
但是在工作这件事情上我值得呀，
人是要拆开来看呢，
那我问你，
就是你是不是还想他呀，
不是想他会让我，
就是感觉他感受我是热智，
他有站在高层次上面的来打压我的那种自悲心的这种感觉，
我们女人啊，
老是陷露那种逻辑，
就说哎呀，
她没瞧上我，
我就没自尊了，
我跟你说你们都去学那个谁袁咏仪，
袁咏仪当时追张智霖嘛，
那人家就说，
那你要是追人家，
人家要是不同意的话，
那你怎么办？
下一个喽，
你们真的都去学一下袁咏仪这种态度，
男人这个东西就是这个不行，
下一个喽，
并如说这个不喜欢我，
就表示我不好，
就表示我不值得，
就表示我没有魅力想上下一个，
因为我感觉我转身期间对不对也是差不多类似，
但是他立即就和前女友和好了，
他们就结婚了，
然。
哦，
我就干掉了，
我就感觉我是不是在感情相处理发誓什么的就很有问题，
感情沟中作需要学习的，
男女相处的技巧、
经验，
解决矛盾的方式都需要学习的，
承认自己现在经验还不够，
男女相处说这话难听，
包括有的时候给男朋友下套儿，
这个事儿的话，
下套的经验不够多，
磨人心的那个火候还没到，
那就得多练，
实话就得多练，
我的我的天然我是一下，
另一方面就是我不是原生家庭，
也不是很好，
我大概来这边之后给家里人去年就是相当于我工作吧，
给家里面大概有20个左右，
因为我父母他们工作很不容易，
就相当于都是在给我弟还房贷，
因为他妈给我弟买了一个房子，
到现在差不多还要还30个，
我其实是有点想在这两年里面把这个钱给他还上，
千万不要这么搞，
搞到最后满期又受伤，
然后没人念你的好，
没有人念你的好，
你自己有房子吗？
你自己有车了吗？
你自己得到提升了吗？
你想报的班你去报了吗？
你想学的技能你学了吗？
你想做的美容项目你做了吗？
你千万别干这种事儿啊，
因为我爸爸看们工们就特别辛苦，
我爸妈外面就是工作的时候就是这样拼命的工作，
给你买房了，
给你买车了吗？
给你成了对让他们，
但是他们的身体会不好，
是你造成的吗？
因为我就是好让他们，
他们的确想法。
你今天把我这话一定要往心里去，
这话是保命的话啊，
就是你强大到比如说你手上有100万的存款，
你说给他个5万八万的不影响我，
那你可以给，
但你手上就这些钱，
你点着小尖去给，
你肯定后悔，
没有不后悔的，
而且人家不念你的好，
等到有一天他非要花钱的时候，
你没钱了，
他还恨你。
人性就这样，
很奇怪，
我之前有没有经历过的，
经过的扣一你踮着脚尖给你，
心里就会有期待，
期待她感恩你，
期待她就就觉得你是一个乖女儿，
好女儿。
但是人的欲望会被喂大的，
等到有一天他的欲望被喂大的时候，
他再想要你拿钱给装修，
再想要你拿钱给彩礼，
你拿不出来的时候，
他就恨你，
你为什么当初要承诺呀，
你为什么当初一定要怎吧吹牛啊，
怎么怎么地的，
明白吗？
我回原了就要罕一变，
你永远记住，
你手上有100万的存款的时候，
你拿个三万五万的不影响你的时候，
看心情，
但是说你手上你自己没房，
你自己没车，
你自己都没找到对象，
你自己都孑然一身，
自己都还没有立住的时候，
你踮着小尖去帮忙，
没有不后悔多存点钱，
天天晚上要这样怎么找对象？
我觉得我的长相也是比较一般嘛，
怎也就是一般，
不是很好看，
如果说自己觉得自己长得不好看的话，
那就让自己变得好看女人，
就算你五官不是很惊艳，
但是皮肤一定要好，
该做的护肤都给我去做，
该。
做美容都给我去做，
实在不行的话，
做微调也是可以的，
拿个双眼皮儿也是可以的，
纹个眉毛拿个双眼皮儿可以，
因为双眼皮儿现在都已经成为非常成熟的手术了，
没有什么风险了，
做个头发也是可以的，
护肤化妆学起来，
那现在在这在这里经做了，
太愿意对认真工作，
努力存钱，
钱要花在自己身上，
钱要花在自己变漂亮，
要花在自己变健康，
要花在自己身材变得匀称，
要花在自己社会关系己变得有价值，
要花在自己能力变更强，
要花在自己生存能力，
竞争能力变得更强，
钱全走花最上头，
他会去教会了，
每次他去的时候，
他就会推荐我过去，
一般是周五晚上和周日上午，
他有生夜，
会问我会不会跟他一起去，
但是他现在我基本然确定他是有对向了，
你不要去，
他不想去找他有，
但是我怕给他锻炼，
还是在他这里把这个工作好好的完成，
因为我们这个工作他可能会有长期间在，
也跟我提到就很长时间这后再留在这个课题组，
这种状态我不确定是不是要留这，
因为其实我是心里还是没有过意放下过去，
但是他告诉我他是已经放下了的，
如果长期留在这里，
有长期的年薪40万的话，
不要跟钱过不去啊，
没有哪个男的值得我放弃年薪40万的工作。
除非直接把1200万现金拍我手上有可能，
否则的话是不会放弃原先富上的工作的，
我天地票成就是那是这样，
你去选的吧，
我那天看到一个采访，
跟大家讲真心话好不好？
采访一个学生说清华北大和一个亿你选哪个？
选清华选北大的就是没有经过社会毒打的，
选一个亿的就是看清了社会真相的，
清华和北大还有一个亿，
你选哪个？
记得点赞关注哦。